Becca serif esta es un una Yoli
traditional traditional comme si me
gusta muharram Angelo viola traditional
Sudheer new Meza Maori pro key frame or
a Michael a trampa fum una mas una Mika
the rubella dog Alfie deyes a cat Rueben
Droughns Aceves por fuera pasa menos
cantidad menos conceited die Akiva
family
rogem Lepard or dreams yo possible in
some order
foreign foreign reviled oh those grants
are vans forum yacht enema pool says
important part a response in Jose Moulin
Rouge arianamichael asado a possible
Minka Dessau Yocum insanity caffeine
Scoob Teddy Munna masa Bend infinita the
frame low frame low E Allison dimitru
can now stream of rubella cleans he poos
mo revenge OCD ok tenkara ya leepu's mo
Ruben EPM commence on mundo strokes es
su dartle doula me cry vocal enter Agua
Caliente Uno's vote azayaka winter qual
Toki
Alan come on Sarah momenta un bono
Liguria versa you know see des Vasa zero
quoi de graça see res Akita ningún
cerana on on Oscar River tsunami
khattala Magua yeoman same premium
documents amo la paka paka
I despise food reminiscence
so emulsion is drops of an immiscible
fluid in a second fluid drops of one
fluid in a second fluid a foam is the
same thing except instead of using a
fluid on the inside of the drops you use
air a gas so how do you make an emulsion
well the best way I can show you is to
do this little experiment here I have
olive oil and water and I'm going to try
to mix them together and olive oil is
not miscible in water and when I pour
the olive oil onto the water it floats
on top it's lighter than the water so
the only way you can mix them is to
shake them so let me shake them like
this and look they do mix but they don't
completely mix instead you form drops of
the oil in the water and that's an
emulsion but let's watch this for a
little while we put on the side remember
the oil is lighter than the water and
it's going to start to flow to the top
and as it floats the drops become closer
and closer and they begin to join
together and they lose their stability
the emulsion doesn't remain drops of one
fluid another but rather phase separates
becomes the two fluids again and if you
look at them if we watch them over time
you see they completely face that way so
this emulsion is not stable so how do we
make an emulsion an emulsion is mixture
of one fluid in a second by making drops
for example in this case we've made oil
drops in water the oil drops are now
called the dispersed phase the water is
called the continuous phase and to make
an emulsion you have to mix them
together somehow you have to form drops
of the dispersed phase in the continuous
phase and when you do that you get these
drops and that's your emulsion but to
make them stable you have to prevent the
drops you have to keep the drops as
individual drops you can't allow them to
join together or coalesce somehow you
have to stabilize the interface of the
drops of the oil in the water and we do
that using a surfactant a surfactant is
a surface active molecule it's an amp of
silica molecule part of it is water like
a hydrophilic and the other part is oil
like or how
phobic and they're joined together so
the surfactant molecules like both the
oil and the water and it can't really
decide which they want so they can't
really sit in either the oil or the
water instead they prefer to sit at the
interface at the surface between the two
fluids typically you put the surfactant
in the continuous phase so if you have
an oil and water emulsion you put the
surfactant in the water so part of the
surfactant sits at the oil there's
excess surfactant however you need to
have access to factions so that you
always have more surfactants available
so that it can come to the interface as
you create the interface when you're
emulsifying something the surfactant has
to come out of the water and go to the
interface however the surfactant does
not like to stay in the water because it
has part of it which is oil like it
doesn't like to be in water so instead
the surfactant forms aggregates we call
these micelles the aggregate so that the
tail groups the oil part of the
surfactants are all connected together
they're all facing one another excluding
some of the water that allow the
surfactant to exist in the water without
exposing the tail groups to the water
itself but the micelles act as a
reservoir they can easily break up and
bring new surfactant to the interface as
you create the interface and if you have
enough surfactant and egg yolk for
example is an excellent surfactant they
completely coat all the interfaces and
then when drops come together as I show
here in this little cartoon when two
drops come together with a coated
interface with a surfactant covered
interface it prevents the drops from
joined together and becoming larger
drops so the drops remain stable and the
emulsion remains stable